in the relation x is equal to y squared
plus three can y be represented as a
mathematical function of x so the way
they've written it x is being
represented as a mathematical function
of y we could even say that x as a
function of y is equal to y squared plus
3. now let's see if we can do it the
other way around if we can represent y
as a function of x so one way you could
think about it is you could essentially
try to solve for y here so let's do that
so i have x is equal to y squared plus
3. subtract 3 from both sides you get x
minus 3 is equal to y squared now the
next step is going to be tricky
x minus 3 is equal to y squared so
y could be equal to and i'm just going
to swap the sides y could be equal to if
we take the square root of both sides it
could be the positive square root of x
minus 3 or it could be the negative
square root or y could be the negative
square root of
x minus 3. if you don't believe me
square both sides of this you'll get y
squared is equal to x minus 3. square
both sides of this you're going to get y
squared is equal to well the negative
squared is just going to be a positive 1
and you're going to get y squared is
equal to
x minus 3. so this is a situation here
where for a given x you could actually
have two y values let me show you so
let's say
let me attempt to sketch this graph
so let's say this is our y axis let's
get i guess i could call it this
relation
this is our
x-axis
and this right over here y is a positive
square root of x minus 3 that's going to
look like this so this is x is equal to
3 it's going to look like this
that's y is equal to the positive square
root of x minus 3
and this over here y is equal to the
negative square root of x minus 3 is
going to look something like this
it's going to look something
that should make a little bit more
symmetric looking because it's going to
essentially be the mirror image if you
flip over the x-axis so it's going to
look something
like this y is equal to the negative
square root of x minus 3. and this right
over here this relationship cannot be
this right over here is not a function
of x for given x in order to be a
function of x for given x it has to map
to exactly one value for the function
but here you see it's mapping to two
values of the function so for example
let's say we take x is equal to four so
x equals four
could get us to y is equal to one four
minus three is one take the positive
square root it could be 1
or
you could have x equals 4 and y is equal
to negative 1. so you can't have the
situation if you were to make a table
x
and
y as a function of x you can't have x is
equal to four and at one point it equals
one and then in another interpretation
of it when x is equal to four you get
two negative one you can't have
one input mapping to two outputs and
still be a function so in this case the
relation cannot
for this relation y cannot be
represented as a mathematical function
of x